British conservatives Boris Johnson
Dominic Cummings and others have been
gaslighting the British people because
what they've been saying is we're going
to control immigration we're going to
lower immigration and then when they
ended up in power they said well
actually we didn't mean lower we just
meant we're going to give you control
why have conservatives responded so
terribly to the realignment of politics
and we talked about this after 2019 I
remember the conversation vividly we
said there is a unique historic
opportunity here for Boris Johnson and
the conservatives to reshape the country
and they squandered that opportunity
they lost that opportunity why did they
I would suggest as I argue in the book
is that because conservative Elites
basically are too culturally liberal and
too economically liberal to connect with
the voters who are looking for somebody
to reassert their values in the system
and so all we've really had since brexit
is a continuation of what you might call
the liberal consensus which is basically
dominated British politics for much of
the last 30 40 years Margaret Thatcher
you know was needed I'm I'm open to I
accept the idea that you know Thatcher's
reforms in my mind at the time they were
needed but what she did is she injected
this radical economic liberalism
deregulated uh the economy liberalize
Finance Embrace globalization or what
Danny Roderick has called hyper
globalization the routine prioritization
of big business or big corporates over
the national community and that was
followed by Blair and Blair then came
along and he injected radical cultural
liberalism he said hey we're going to
strip away the borders of the national
Community we're gonna have mass
immigration we're going to have European
integration we're going to take
meaningful Choice out of politics left
and right are essentially going to
become the same thing brexit populism
the realignment were really an attempt
by voters to break that consensus to
challenge that consensus and what we can
now see is that actually uh those
revolts have failed to do that and that
the elite the new graduate Elite
socially liberal if not radically
Progressive has reasserted its political
and cultural power uh and push back uh
that that Rebellion do you think that
part of the reason why things aren't as
heated anymore is because of the brexit
referendum yet we look at countries like
Italy like Spain and they're very much
still in the throes of populism yeah I
think it's remarkable that Britain now
is one of the only Western democracies
to not have a successful populist
movement and when I wrote my last book
National populism a lot of people were
critical they said well these movements
are going to be a flash in the pan
they're going to rapidly disappear look
at the elections last year France Sweden
Spain Portugal Italy Hungary record
levels of support for National populist
parties meanwhile the Republicans fell
short in the U.S but they took back the
house Ronda santis now or Trump probably
have a realistic chance of winning the
presidency uh uh next year so populism
is still here but in Britain bizarrely
it's it's absent and the reason for that
is because the conservatives basically
hoovered up Nigel farage's vote they
hoovered up a lot of these voices who
took a pump on on Boris Johnson and they
said look if you're going to be the guy
that's going to shake up this consensus
if you're going to deliver brexit if
you're going to reform immigration if
you're going to push back against the
woke we're going to give you a chance
and what happened Johnson basically let
them down Johnson
did the reverse on a lot of that stuff I
mean one of the untold stories about
British politics today which I don't
think many people out there have yet
realized is the extent to which Boris
Johnson and the conservatives
liberalized the immigration system in
Britain to the point that we now have
000 uh uh uh as a net migration
um level the highest we've we've ever
had uh just to make the point they
promised that it would go down David
Cameron promised to the tens of
thousands yeah so what's happened is
British conservatives Boris Johnson
Dominic Cummings and others have been
gaslighting the British people because
what they've been saying is we're going
to control immigration we're going to
lower immigration and then when they
ended up in power they said well
actually we didn't mean lower we just
meant we're going to give you control
uh but what is clear I'm running polls
every week most people out there want
immigration lowered end of story ideally
around 100 000 certainly not five
hundred thousand and worst bit of all of
it is Johnson not only liberalizes
migration to this unprecedented extent
but he even does stuff like removes the
requirement for British companies to
advertise jobs in Britain so what you
see contrary to the um the desire
through the brexit vote to put the
national Community First is you
basically see conservatives perhaps best
symbolized by Liz Truss
kind of doubling down on this hyper
globalization Mass immigration
london-centric model built around
Financial Services uh and basically
putting their fingers up at many of the
voters who turned to them in 2019 and
thought well gee maybe these are the
people that are going to break up the
consensus so I suspect that the real
winner at the next election won't
actually be the labor party in kirstama
it would be apathy it would be a lot of
people saying you know what I try to
change a system I try to regain my voice
I try to reassert my values nobody's
interested
foreign